heute reden wir über die präposition bei
dass deutsche bei ist ähnlich zu der
englischen position bei aber im
deutschen kann diese position viel mehr
bedeutungen haben zum beispiel kann man
sie übersetzen mit bei vor
vornholt gering hier
und weil bei wird immer mit dem dativ
gebildet wo bist du
ich bin bei meiner mutter wo bist du
jetzt
ich war gerade beim arzt ich bin bei dir
wenn man bei mit dem kombiniert sagt man
beim beim warten auf den bus hat janis
eine idee ich hab eine geniale idee
ich war gerade beim supermarkt hier noch
ein paar weitere beispiele für
situationen in denen man bei benutzt hat
wollen wir einen kaffee trinken gehen
sorry ich bin noch vor der arbeit bei
welchem arzt warst du bei dem an der
ecke ich hab jetzt endlich angefangen
house of cards zu gucken
bei welcher staffel besteht erst bei der
zweiten
wo finde ich hier einen guten töne da
drüben bei der u bahn haltestelle ist
ein ganz runter was hast du geld dabei
nee ich hab nichts von mir kannst du
noch schnell bei der bank was abgeben
okay ich bin jetzt bei der bank wie
vielseitig abheben
und hier sind noch drei fragen für euch
um die präposition weiß bei wem wollt
ihr bei sie arbeitet ihr und bei welchem
supermarkt kauft ihr ein
[Musik]